[Music]
as we look ahead to an all-electric
future we really talk about not leaving
anyone behind
the san joaquin valley in california it
has some major challenges
it's got some of the most severe poverty
and the worst air quality in the entire
united states
the transportation industry is really at
an inflection point we've got to
fundamentally transform this whole
sector of the economy and this
particularly includes the communities
that are hardest hit by climate change
what valley clean air now is looking at
is how do we bring climate equity to the
places that need it most there's a lot
of need and people rely on these
vehicles
at our event here today we've got
hundreds of people who need help with
their smog repairs when we look at
transitioning into an electric vehicle
future it's important to remember it's
not there for everyone yet
the older the vehicle the higher the
emissions are going to be so we've
offered them 850 in repairs which
typically fixes
[Music]
we're also going to educate them on the
fact that we can help them replace their
older vehicle with a used electric
vehicle
we need to figure out how to do this in
a way that provides benefits for
everyone and doesn't leave anyone behind
[Music]
right now for electric vehicles they're
so new that we don't have enough
electric vehicle technicians out there
yet
i've always wanted to learn this
it's the future for me
[Music]
the only way to create those technicians
are really passionate expert instructors
when the opportunity arose to work with
valley cannon in order to develop this
training it was a no-brainer
one of my passions is helping students
transition from education into the
workforce the market is growing quickly
we need to really grow the pool of
people who have the skills and knowledge
to work on electric vehicles i feel like
this class is going to be a solution to
a big problem the change is going to
happen fast and it's exciting that i'm
getting my foot in the door to learn
about that change there's this mentality
out there that i've noticed where it's
almost like people consider these to be
ufos
they're still vehicles it's all stuff
that's held together with nuts and bolts
it's just the
technology that propels it down the road
is
different
having this class means a lot you know
it gives me an edge in this growing
industry it's going to help myself and
my family this is no longer car
mechanics as we used to think of it
this is more a technology job this new
generation of electric vehicle
technicians in five or ten years they've
got enormous career opportunities
they're going to be the hands-on
innovators that really make electric
vehicles work for america there is an
opportunity out there if you're willing
to take it and doors will open up if
you're willing to take a chance
i want to be a part of that change
[Music]
you